Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass, heute mit ein bisschen Podcast-Pflege. Heute habe ich Jens Huiber bei mir zum Gast vom Spartradio 360. Was das alles mit Fußball zu tun hat, das werdet ihr gleich erfahren, jetzt im 56. Kurzpass. Jens, endlich mal der Gegenbesuch. Seien wir willkommen.
Es wird eh schon Zeit. Ich hatte schon ein ganz schlechtes Gewissen. Hier in der Nähe des FC Bayern München, wo sich die großartigen Rasenfunkstudios, ist für mich ein Auswärtsspiel. Ich sag dir, wie es ist. Ja. Und zwar in mehrerer Hinsicht. Der FC Bayern München ist ja nicht mein Herzensklub, aber ich akzeptiere und ich freue mich manchmal über die Leistungen.
Mehr will ich gar nicht erreichen. Damit haben wir schon alles erreicht. Aber hier darfst du dich heimisch fühlen. Wir sind im 1 gegen 1. Du bist nicht in der Unterzahl. Du befindest dich hier in Studios, die nicht mal einen Namen haben. Ich meine, du nimmst in den David Alaba Studios auf.
Und ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das darf. Das ist die große Frage. Hat sich David Alaba A, weisert? Ich glaube nicht. B, wenn er es wüsste, wie würde er reagieren? Würde er sich geehrt fühlen oder würde er sagen, was machen die da mit meinem Namen?
Mein First Guest wäre, wenn du ihm sagst, dass du hin und wieder auch in den David Alaba Studios betest, dann ist es für ihn okay.
Das ist wahr. Also dieses Foto, ich dachte zuerst, ist es Neymar. Ich weiß nicht, ob du es retweetet hast, aber ich weiß nicht.
Ich halte mich auf so was raus.
Ich dachte, Neymar geht da die Treppe hoch und hat ein sehr großes Bild von sich im Wohnzimmer hängen. Aber es war dann doch David Alaba. Stark.
Ja, aber erstaunlicherweise wollen wir nicht mal darüber reden. Obwohl sowas so häufig Teil des Rasenfunks ist. Nein, wir wollen heute über ein Projekt reden, das du mit vielen anderen, aber hauptverantwortlich du mal wieder, auf die Beine gestellt hast. Und zwar im Rahmen des Sportradio 360. Sag mal, was kann man denn von dir zur WM bekommen?
Ich habe mal ein bisschen rumgefragt, Leute, von denen ich weiß, dass sie A gut schreiben können und B gerne schreiben. Zum Beispiel ein gewisser Max-Jakob Ost. Den habe ich auch gefragt. Ich habe ein WM-Magazin gemacht. Jetzt kann man sagen, das machen alle anderen auch. Ja, ist mir eigentlich egal. Ich habe es auch gemacht. Mein WM-Magazin ist jetzt nicht Zahlen, Daten, Fakten, so wie man es vielleicht vom Kicker bekommt. Das ist natürlich auch eine Übersicht über die Spiele, mit Spielplan, alles drin. Aber ich habe versucht, Texte einzufangen von lieben Menschen, die bei mir öfter mal dabei sind, die auch Themen behandeln, die vielleicht in anderen Heften nicht vorkommen. Ich habe diese Themen teilweise auf Frage vorgegeben. Ich habe aber, so wie du, sprechen wir gleich darüber, dass du auch was geschrieben hast, wo ich gesagt habe, such dir was aus. Und du hast sofort gesagt, okay, ich habe eine Idee. Und das war eine gute Idee. Und es ist wirklich sehr, sehr toll geschrieben, was du gemacht hast. Und ich habe halt, ja, doch 18 Leute haben mir was geschrieben. Und viele andere, die jetzt gesagt haben, okay, liegt mir nicht so, aber ich habe gerade keine Zeit. Die haben sich dann auch nochmal eingebracht mit eben ein paar Gedanken über ihre WM-Erfahrung. Und das habe ich auf 60 Seiten komprimiert. Das Ganze nennt sich Hashtag 12 Titelverteidiger. Da gibt es natürlich jetzt, wir werden gleich vielleicht aufs Titelbild zu sprechen kommen, kleine Probleme mit den Titelverteidigern, weil die Auswahl ist ja nicht mehr ganz so groß und ich finde, ich habe eine...
12 sind es nicht mehr, ne?
Kommen wir noch auf 12. Matze Ginther, der könnte es rausreißen als Titelverteidiger.
Ich glaube, 9 von der WM 2014 sind jetzt im Vorlauf im Kader, aber ganz sicher bin ich mir auch nicht. Ich bin noch im Bundesliga-Rückschaum-Modus, noch nicht im WM-Vorausblick-Modus. Du bist quasi mein Einstieg in die WM-Zeit.
Das ist großartig, ja. Und ich hätte es gerne physisch mitgebracht. Es ist gerade im Druck und es wird nächste Woche erwartet. Und dann geht es natürlich raus, das WM-Magazin, 60 Seiten. Und ich war dann schon, es sind ein paar Leute dabei, die mir absolutes Anliegen waren. Nicht nur unsere Stammgäste, dass die immer dabei sind. Aber ich möchte gleich mit der Tür ins Haus fallen. Also wer die Süddeutsche Zeitung liest, Holger Gertz hat was geschrieben und Holger hat das natürlich. Ja, er will nix dafür. Also niemand bekommt hier was dafür. Ich werde auch nicht reich und berühmt, aber das wollte ich machen und jetzt habe ich es gemacht. Dankenswerterweise gibst du mir hier die Möglichkeit, dass ich es an deine Hörer weitertrage.
Absolut. Also das muss man wirklich sagen. Allein die Auswahl der Menschen da ist herausragend. Holger Gertz schreibt die besten dritten Seiten in der Süddeutschen Zeitung. Das ist unumstritten und es ist auch schön, ganz viele Texte von Leuten zu lesen, die man sehr häufig bei dir hört, vor allem in der Big Show, die ich jedem sehr ans Herz legen möchte. Die Big Show erscheint jeden Donnerstag Nachmittag. Ist perfekt, danach wisst ihr über alle anderen Sportarten auch Bescheid, nicht nur über Fußball. Und zu Fußball bekommt ihr auch noch ein paar andere Perspektiven als immer nur dieses Gelaber hier im Rasenfunk. Also wirklich tolle Autoren mit drin und von denen mal was zu lesen, auch mal von Dre Fogt ein geschriebenes Wort zu lesen, das ist doch wirklich was wert.
Unsere Basketballfreunde in der Five lesen natürlich ab und zu was von Dre und Dre hat aber natürlich Bezug genommen auf einen Spieler, der ihm sehr am Herzen gelegen ist, wo ihm jetzt das Herz noch Blut hat. Der Trennungsschmerz ist nach wie vor da. Also er hat wirklich einen ganz netten, ich meine, eine kleine Reportage, einen Stimmungsbericht über eben Kevin de Bruyne geschrieben. Und das ist eben der Anspruch gewesen.
Ich dachte schon, du sagst Julian Draxler, aber...
Ja, der kommt jetzt das nächste. Das ist der next step dann.
Da hat er sich noch nicht rangetraut, hat sich jetzt warm geschrieben mit Kevin de Bruyne. Und dann kommt die Hommage an Julian Draxler.
Da muss ich erst was senken, setzen bei Dre. Aber die Idee war eben auch, dass man aus einer persönlichen Perspektive heraus was schreibt. Manche werden wollte. Und Dre, ja, du bist ein Wolfsburg-Fan, hat ja auch am Donnerstagabend im Wölferradio kommentiert und hat über Kevin de Bruyne geschrieben. Und auch Frank Fliege, der ein sehr langes Stück über Mario Götze geschrieben hat, der wahrscheinlich nicht dabei sein wird, außer Joachim Löw, brechen alle Stützen weg. Und er sagt dann, okay, ich nehme ihn.
Das ist übrigens mein Lieblingsszenario fürs erste Training, ohne dass ich jemand eine Verletzung wünsche. Aber wenn Nils Petersen und Mario Gomez in einem Luftzweikampf so zusammenrauschen, dass sie nicht zur WM können, dann hätte ich gerne ein Livestream des Gesichts von Sandro Wagner.
Die Nummer 2 ist nicht verfügbar.
Ja, das ist eine interessante Entscheidung. Aber eigentlich gar nicht so überraschend. Also Nils Petersen fand ich überraschend. Aber wenn Löw die Wahl hat zwischen Gomes und Wagner, die vom Spielertyp her ähnlich sind, dann stand das immer minimum 50-50 zwischen den beiden.
Ja, und wenn man überlegt, dass die jetzt vielleicht sogar 6 Wochen zusammen sind im Trainingslager und ich stelle mir den Wagner anstrengend vor. Und ich stelle ihn mir unterhaltsam vor für ein paar Minuten, aber für 6 Wochen vielleicht auch im Umgang ein bisschen anstrengend.
Ja, ich weiß es nicht. Ich meine, da müsste man ihn jetzt natürlich persönlich kennen, um das zu sagen.
Ich würde es ja mal begrüßen. Ich fürchte nur, dass die Interviewanfrage an den FC Bayern München vielleicht bei dir freundlich negativ beschrieben wird.
Ja, das könnte natürlich sein. Ich war auf einer Veranstaltung unter anderem mit Markus Hörwig. Da wurde darüber diskutiert, wie das Podcast und große Boulevardmedien, wie sich der Sportjournalismus verändert hat. Und da hat er die großartige Argumentationskette aufgemacht. Erst hat er gesagt, ja, es ist ja fürchterlich, wie Boulevardmedien inzwischen über Fußball sprechen. Das kann man nicht mehr akzeptieren. Und als wir zehn Minuten später darüber geredet haben, dass der Rasenfunk mal was zu Alain Robben machen könnte, hat es irgendjemand aus dem Publikum gesagt. Er hat gesagt, Entschuldigung, wie viel hören dich? Ja, nee, komm, das ist ja lächerlich.
Ist es aber nicht. Es ist nicht lächerlich, weil ich weiß ja von größeren Internetportalen, wie viele Leute Artikel lesen.
Das stimmt.
Und klar, Spiegel Online wird wahrscheinlich mehr Abrufe haben als du. Ich meine, du hast ja doppelt oder dreifach so viel wie ich. Aber es ist dann nicht so schlecht im Vergleich. Wenn man sieht –und ich nehme mal Bezug auf Tennis –wenn man sieht, Angie Kerber gewinnt die Australian Open und dann siehst du den betreffenden Artikel dafür –gut, da haben vielleicht mehr darüber berichtet –aber das sind dann nicht wesentlich mehr Leser als zum Beispiel die Big Show Downloaden, dann denke ich mir, wir müssen uns das da nicht kleiner machen als wir sind.
Ja, das stimmt schon und es ist halt eine andere Medienart. Also kann ich ja nichts dafür, dass es jetzt noch nicht den großen –gut, jetzt gibt's ein Bild-Podcast, wobei die auch einen anderen inhaltlichen Schwerpunkt setzen, das ist ganz angenehm. Also ich würde ihn jetzt nicht als Konkurrenz bezeichnen. Aber ja, können wir ja nichts für das Indie-Medium jetzt halt bisher noch keine unterwegs, sondern dann machen wir es halt selber. Aber es ist halt so die grundsätzliche Frage, wie du das, was man macht mit all seinem Herzblut, wie du das einordnest und ob du da nur nach den Reichweiten gehst oder auch nach anderen Kriterien.
Ja, mir ist es halt ein Anliegen, ich möchte mit den Leuten reden über Sportarten, die mich interessieren, wo ich weiß, die sind nah dran und jetzt bin ich halt Leit oder zum Glück Österreich. Also im Winter muss bei mir halt jede Woche der Skisport drinnen sein. Ist halt einfach so. Und dann versucht mal den Jede Huiber von eurer Sport dazu zu nehmen, weil der bei den Rennen ist und der ist Leitner vom ORF. Und das brauche ich halt ein kleines bisschen, weil ich weiß, der hat am Vormittag mit dem Hirscher geredet, wie er sich eingefahren ist und da habe ich dann eine andere Perspektive. Und deswegen, das, was ich mache, ist halt mehr ein bisschen Sportschau, von jedem ein bisschen was und ich versuche halt schon das Beste und beim Fußball ist halt manchmal wirklich so, dass ich sehr froh bin, dass Andreas Reiner dabei ist, weil Andreas immer von allen Seiten alles beheuchtet.
Und auch sehr gerne die Antithese vertreten.
Ja, natürlich.
Da kann man drauf gefasst sein, immer wenn ein Gast im Fußball-Segment länger als 2.30 redet, dann wird Andreas Reiner gleich nochmal was sagen.
Ein Punkt noch.
Was wir aber auch sagen müssen, ist...
Da kommt er immer dazu.
Okay, aber kommen wir mal zurück auf zwölf Titelverteidiger. Wo kann man denn überhaupt dieses Erzeugnis mal erwerben?
Also, am besten ihr schreibt mir eine Mail, steilpass.at.sportradio360.de oder ihr, wir haben das ja gar nicht abgesprochen, ihr kontaktiert den Max und der Max leitet es mir weiter.
Ja, könnt ihr auch machen, ja.
Aber steilpass.at.sportradio360.de und das ist in einer sehr kleinen Auflage erschienen.
Also sprich, es hat schon jetzt einen Sammlerwert, will er damit andeuten?
Ja, das möchte ich damit andeuten. Es kosten Zehner. Ich sage euch auch warum. Ich habe natürlich die Fotos bezahlen müssen. Die Autoren, die waren alle, die haben gesagt, okay, das machen wir, überhaupt kein Thema. Die Fotos, da muss man die Rechte einkaufen. Das hat schon ein bisschen Geld gekostet, aber okay, mir war es das wert und der Druck, der hat Flyer-Alarm auch nicht gesagt. Komm, geile Sache, das machen wir dir umsonst. Und da ist auch noch eine kleine Spende dabei und da ist aber das Porto dabei natürlich. Also für einen Zehner bekommt ihr eine Rechnung geschickt, steilpass.edsportrader360.de. Ja, und dann bekommt ihr das zugeschickt, so wie es da ist. Die Logistikabteilung in den David-Alaba-Studios ist vorbereitet auf den Ansturm von einigen. Ich möchte das Ziel nicht zu hoch ausrufen.
Ja, schauen wir mal. Also es ist das Independent-Projekt unter den WM-Magazinen. Eigentlich ist es ja fast schon Mainstream, inzwischen ein eigenes WM-Magazin rauszugeben. Wenn ich mir angucke, was es da alles gibt. Olli Wurm hat sein Ding etabliert. Dann gibt es jetzt eine Initiative in Baden-Württemberg. Da hängt Roland Eitel mit drin. Aber ich sage mal so, und das kann man, das kann man glaube ich schon so stehen lassen, das Independent-Projekt aus dem Untergrund, aus dem Münchner Untergrund.
Und zwar buchstäblich.
Wir sitzen hier natürlich im zweiten OG, aber...
Ich möchte sagen Penthouse. Wir müssen uns erst hocharbeiten, wo Max Ost mit seinem Rasenfunk schon ist. Wir sind noch wirklich im Untergrund. Und ja, das ist das Projekt jetzt, das ich mir für dieses Jahr gegönnt habe.
Ich weiß aber ehrlich gesagt nicht, ob du dich hocharbeiten musst oder ob ich nicht runtergearbeitet werde. Meine Theorie ist ja, sobald meine Kinder so alt sind, dass sie Stimmrecht haben in diesem Haushalt, werde ich auch in den Keller vertrieben.
Ich möchte dich nicht auf mein Niveau herabziehen, Max. Das wäre ganz, ganz schlimm.
Okay, aber lassen wir noch ein bisschen mehr über das Heftchen reden. Also, wir haben schon gehört, dass Dre Fogt was geschrieben hat über Julian Draxl oder Kevin de Bruyne.
Man weiß es nicht, ich habe es schon vergessen.
Muss man bestellen, um das herauszufinden. Was haben wir denn noch so Schönes?
Na, wir haben natürlich einige historische Dinge und erstaunlicherweise drehen sich doch –und Vorsicht da draußen, bitte –es hat schon eine Welt vor 1990 gegeben. Ich glaube, die Demografie deiner Hörer ist deutlich jünger, 25 und jünger, aber es dreht sich doch, es drehen sich einige Themen, zum Beispiel über die FußballwM 1978. Das war die, ich habe damals nicht verstanden, was so besonders dran ist, a, dass sich Österreich qualifiziert und b, dass Österreich dann Deutschland schlägt. Das wurde mir dann nachher erzählt, dass das was ganz Besonderes ist, es geht aber tatsächlich um Cordoba. Unser lieber Freund, das darf ich glaube ich sagen, Alex Feuerherd, hat eine tolle Geschichte geschrieben über den Schiedsrichter des Spiels Österreich gegen Deutschland. Und wer es kennt und wer kennt es nicht, von Chrisemann und Stermann gibt es ja diese herrliche Parodie auf dieses Cordobaspiel, wo 22 deutsche Sportkammeraden von einem israelischen Schiedsrichter auch noch auf All People angeleitet werden und da hat Alex Feuerherd, das war im 78 und dieser Abraham Klein hat dann auch noch 82 gepfiffen und das ist zum Beispiel eine Geschichte, die ich überhaupt nicht wusste und ich habe Alex gefragt, magst du was schreiben für das WM-Magazin? Ich habe jetzt überhaupt keine Idee, was du schreiben möchtest und Alex hat sofort gesagt Abraham Klein. Und Alex hat auch, weil ich gesagt habe, er hat mir ungefähr 5000 Zeichen, ich wäre ein schöner, da mache ich mehr und für mehr habe ich immer Zeit und Raum und Freude und dann hat es sich eben so ergeben, dass exakt zur selben Wettmeisterschaft, da waren ja die Holländer im Finale gegen Argentinien, ich geisle mich heute noch mit der sieben Schwänzigen, dass ich damals, ich habe es nicht verstanden, die politische Komponente, ich habe damals mit Argentinien mitgehalten. Ich weiß, mein Vater hat drei Freunde bei uns zu Hause in unserem kleinen Wohnzimmer gehabt, die haben alle geraucht. Also, wenn mich mal der Lungenkrebs dahin rafft, dann weiß ich, warum, aus dieser Zeit.
Das wäre im Finale 78.
Die haben alle mit Holland mitgehalten und ich habe aber Mario Kempels gesehen dort, mit seinen langen Haaren und dann schießt er auch noch die Tore und Rob Rensenbrink, du weißt das, er hätte ja fast in der, ich glaube, die 82. Minute war so oder vielleicht sogar noch später dieses Tor geschossen und das war im Ernst Hubble gegen Cesar Luis Menotti, zwei Legenden und natürlich, danach bin ich auch draufgekommen, ich dolm als Österreicher, ich hätte mit Holland mithalten müssen, auch wegen Hubble und Holger Gertz hat eben dieses Duell, Hubble gegen Cesar Luis Menotti aufgearbeitet und Holger ist ein Genie, muss ich sagen. Ich versuche mich ja auch als Schreiberling, aber wenn du einen Text von Holger Gertz liest, finde ich, wenn du die Seite drei liest, da sind dann zwei Sätze drinnen, von denen ich weiß, ich hätte mich noch so anstrengen können, ich hätte es nicht geschafft. Und das sind ganz einfache Sätze, aber wie er sie einsetzt, Holger, das ist fantastisch. Ja, und das ist 1978 ist ein Thema, aber wir gehen auch zurück zu natürlich zu WM 2014. Heiko Ulderb war dort, der große Heiko Ulderb hatte in Sao Paulo sein Headquarter gehabt und hat aber dann, ist dann nach Rio gefahren, ist auch in Belo Horizonte gewesen und Heiko beschreibt auch, wie ich finde, erstens mal sehr lustig, wie das denn ist, wenn man dort auch ein Journalist unterwegs ist, dann Frank Flige, hat sich eben Mario Goetze angenommen, weil du vorhin gesagt hast, Seite 3-Schreiber Holger Gertz, wir haben Thomas Hahn von der Süddeutschen Zeitung, auch ein lieber Freund, der sich ein bisschen um die Sportpolitik gekümmert hat, der jetzt auch letzte Woche in der Süddeutschen Zeitung eine Seite 3 geschrieben hat über die Wohnverhältnisse in Hamburg. Ich weiß nicht, wer es gelesen hat, aber schön, es war schön geschrieben, aber schön war es nicht, worüber geschrieben hat. Saskia Alleite von der Süddeutschen, die war zwei Jahre nach der WM, war bei den Olympischen Spielen in Rio de Janeiro und hat sich mal angeschaut, was wird denn aus diesen Wettkampfstätten? Und auch bezuggenommen jetzt auf Russland, was wird denn dann dort mit diesen neuen Stadien? Da gibt es ja eine, dieses absurde Stadion, ich weiß nicht, wo es steht, wo die Tribüne dann, das schaut ja komplett schief aus, wo die rausgebaut wird. Aber ja, das sind eben auch Themen, die uns beschäftigen und dann geht es eben auch um Spieler. Du selbst, wir wollen nicht verraten, aber du hast einen Spieler gewürdigt, den ich als komplett unterschätzt einschätze, immer noch.
Es wird der großartigste Trainer Deutschlands seit ganz vielen Jahren werden.
Ja, ich hoffe das. Ich hoffe das, weil ich finde, in seiner Bayern-Zeit haben alle über den falschen Spieler gesprochen.
Ja, genau. Richtig, exakt. Ja, und vor allem, naja gut, ich will nicht zu viel vornehmen, aber das, was du gesagt hast mit den hervorragenden Sätzen und wo man einfach sieht, warum die viele Leute, die hier geschrieben haben, hauptberuflich schreiben, das war genau der Grund, warum ich aus dem geschriebenen Journalismus raus bin. Weil ich das auch irgendwann gesehen habe, dass das so ein Level ist, da kommst du dann mit Fleiß nicht mehr hin, sondern das ist eine Gabe. Und dann dachte ich, warum soll ich mich dann immer in einem Metier messen, wo ich sowieso nie mal wirklich mitspielen kann.
Das ist es. Also wenn man sieht, David Nienhuis ist ja auch dabei und David schreibt auch für verschiedene Outlets und der hat einen ganz besonderen Bezug zu Japan. Und das sind viele Künstler einfach dabei, die schreiben können und wer gerne liest. Und das ist aber nicht so, dass man jetzt drei Tage braucht, um das ganze Teil durchzulesen, die zwölf Titel verteidigen. Sondern es sind natürlich Bilder drinnen und ich denke schon, dass für viele was dabei ist als Thema. Wenn wir auch gerade wieder auf Spieler kommen, Alexi Menü hat da was geschrieben und Alexi, wenn man bei mir hört, manchmal nimmt er keine Gefangene. Alexi, der gute Mann, der hat eine ganz klare Meinung. Dafür, dass er ein Franzose ist, sieht er die Franzosen extrem kritisch. Und vielleicht mit Recht.
Aber allein deshalb lohnt es sich übrigens, die Big Show zu hören. Ich weiß noch genau, er hat bei dir im Frühjahr vor dem Coman-Wechsel, hat er gesagt, ach ja, es ist schon klar, dass noch ein zweiter Franzose zu Bayern kommt von Juwel. Ich sage jetzt noch nicht wen, aber das war dann nicht so schwierig, sich das dann zu überlegen. Das hat er einfach so rausgehauen, hat aber auch nicht sich damit gebrüstet, dass er das weiß, sondern hat im Grunde gesagt, ach das weiß jeder, komm, ist doch klar, das mag ich.
Das ist Alexi, der wirklich eine ganz kritische Beziehung zu, also er liebt den FC Bayern, das wissen wir, aber zu den Franzosen, ich glaube trotzdem, dass er das objektiv richtig, soweit ich das einschätzen kann, bewertet. Also der hat was verfasst und da gibt es ein schönes Gespräch, wie ich finde, zwischen Thomas Wagen und Marco Hagemann, die ja auch lange dabei sind. Marco ist ein Mann der fast ersten Stunde, wir haben 2011 begonnen und das muss ich auch mal sagen, der Marco ist der netteste Kollege, den man sich, ich weiß noch, bei dir schon zu Gast war, aber Marco ist einfach so wahnsinnig nett, das ist großartig.
Cool.
Ja, muss man wirklich sagen.
Du bist nämlich viel näher dran an den Sportmoderatorengrößen.
Na ja, gut, das ist auch wieder Andreas Rehner geschuldet. Wir haben ja ganz klein begonnen, 2011, bei mir damals im Wohnzimmer, dann hat meine Frau mich rausgeschmissen aus dem Wohnzimmer und gesagt, was soll dieses riesen Mischpult da, das brauche ich nicht. Und dann sind wir in den Keller gegangen und das erste Mal sind wir in den Stadtgegangen, 2005. Wolf Fuss, Michael Leopold, Michael Körner, Markus Graub, eigentlich Markus Graub. 2005 war zu früh.
Was ein Line-up.
Ja, war gut damals. Wir haben uns wirklich täglich getroffen im Schatten des Leierkastens in München. Wer München kennt, weiß, dass das eines der bekannteren Bordelle ist. Aber gut, daneben war im Bürogebäude, wo ich die Möglichkeit hatte. Und da sind dann für drei Wochen wirklich jeden Tag immer zwei dieser hoch bezahlten Fachkräfte von Premiere damals gekommen. Also Körner war nicht bei Premiere, sondern war bei Sport 1, oder war immer damals. Beim DSF hieß es ja noch. Aber damals war die Zeit noch nicht reif. Und dann ist das mal ausgelaufen nach zwei Monaten, weil wir gesehen haben, in der 200 Leute zuhören. Und Wolfoos war damals schon teuer, hat aber trotzdem gesagt, okay, das mache ich jetzt einfach, das schaue ich mir an, das interessiert mich. Und 2011 haben wir es wieder aufgenommen und da war nur, weil GAUB mir gegenüber war, ein GAUB-Krawinkel und Renner. Aber Renner hat dann sein goldenes Adressbuch aufgemacht. Da alles drinsteht, man glaubt es nicht. Und so hat sich das ein bisschen entwickelt. Und deswegen habe ich jetzt hier viele Leute, es sind auch ein paar Leute, die gerne was geschrieben hatten, aber die krank geworden sind oder die jetzt irgendwie keine Zeit gehabt haben. Und jetzt ist es halt eine große Breite, die sich aber natürlich wirklich eigentlich auf Andreas Renner beruft, der mir die Kontakte hergestellt hat.
Ein Teufelskerl in so vielen Dingen.
Und keine Show, ich lade ihn bitte mal ein zu dir. Zur zweiten Liga ist der Andreas ein Fuchs.
Unglaublich, er ist das offenste und dickste Buch aller Zeiten, was ich jemals zum Fußball gesehen habe. Ja, das stimmt. Ja, die zweite Liga kommt hier ja zu kurz, aber da seid ihr ja besonders stark aufgestellt, was ich schon für interessante Interviews bei euch gehört habe. Ich fand jetzt gerade das mit Achim Bayer-Lorzer, das fand ich so interessant. Ich habe ja allen Eintracht-Fankfurt-Fans, die hören oder es nicht hören wollten, gesagt, sie sollen Bayer-Lorzer holen, weil der halt beides kann, gegen den Ball und mit dem Ball. Unglaublich gut. Und ihr hattet schon so viele mit dabei, Thorsten Lieberknecht. Ich habe kurz versucht, die Folge zu finden mit Thorsten Lieberknecht, weil ich noch mal in dieses Interview reinhören wollte, jetzt nachdem er gehen musste.
Thorsten Lieberknecht erfüllt mich auch ein kleines bisschen mit Stolz, weil mir da Andreas Reinig gesagt hat, niemals macht er das. Und dann habe ich öfter mal angefragt bei Eintracht Braunschweig und die Dame war immer sehr nett, hatte mich immer vertröstet. Und dann hat sie gesagt, okay, nächste Woche können wir es machen. Und für solche Interviews ist Andreas natürlich großartig, weil er sich super vorbereitet, weil er genau spricht. Wir hatten Frank Kramer, das hat mir gut gefallen. Das habe ich dann endlich mal verstanden. Frank Kramer hat so in klaren Worten erklärt, wie man in der zweiten Liga Fußball spielen muss. Um was zu reißen. Da brauche ich eben dann Leute wie Andreas, das kann ich nicht. Da fehlt mir, wenn ich höre, wie du mit den Leuten redest. Und auch wenn du bei mir die paar Mal zu Gast warst, da denke ich mir, der hat eine Ahnung und du bist in der Materie drin. Das ist großartig, das bin ich nicht.
Ich bin dafür halt nur in einer Materie drin. Und das Wissen über alle anderen Sportarten, hole ich mir ungelogen über die Big Show. Du bist halt der Allrounder. Ich bin halt, ich weiß nicht, ich bin Luca Toni.
Wir sprachen gerade von ihm.
Genau, wir sprachen gerade von ihm. Wer jetzt schlau zugehört hat, weiß jetzt auch so ungefähr, in welche Richtung wir vorhin gesprochen haben. Aber mich kannst du halt nur auf einer Position einsetzen.
Ja, aber die fühlst du natürlich großartig aus.
Du bist halt Polyvalent, wie es Polyvalenta nicht ginge. Wobei ich gar nicht weiß, ob Polyvalent gesteigert werden darf. Vermutlich nicht.
Gibt es da einen Komparativ? Wahrscheinlich nicht. Man müsste Marcel Reif fragen. Der hat Polyvalent, ich weiß nicht, ob er es erfunden hat. Aber er hat es gerne eingesetzt.
Und Lucien Favre natürlich. Den können wir ja bald wieder fragen.
Das ist die Frage. Wird Lucien Favre mit uns reden? Das habe ich in der Big Show eben gehört, dass Lucien Favre nicht mit jedem redet. Das könnte schwierig werden. Aber vielleicht hat er in Frankreich jetzt wieder seine Lieben neu zur Podcast entdeckt.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob ich mich darauf verlassen würde. Bei Lucien Favre bin ich da jetzt nicht so ganz sicher. Aber meinem Gefühl nach ist es, man muss Leute anfragen, die das Medium an sich einfach gerade aus irgendeinem Grund spannend finden. Und dann sagen die erst mal, ich auch mal. Und dann stellen sie fest, ach, das ist einfach nur wie ein langes, ungeschnittenes Radio-Interview. Aber dann haben wir unsere Aufnahme schon im Kasten. Und sie fanden es ja vielleicht nicht schlecht.
Das ist tatsächlich so. Ich habe Thomas Gottschalk angefragt, weil ich Thomas ein bisschen kenne. Und Thomas hat mir das Interview zugesagt.
Stark!
Und hat dann aber irgendwie, hat er dann nicht begriffen, was genau ich mache. Dass das ein Podcast ist. Er hat gedacht, das ist irgendwas mit Facebook Live. Und nee, das will ich nicht. Und dieses neumodische Zeugs. Das war vor einem Jahr. Und jetzt twittert er plötzlich als Herbstblond. Und ich bin leider nicht dazu gekommen, mit Thomas zu sprechen. Ich darf Thomas sagen, weil ich früher mit ihm gearbeitet habe. Ich lasse es auch gerne raushängen. Ich sag dir, wie es ist. Aber es ist mit ihm auch schwierig, über Sport zu reden. Aber ich hätte halt gerne über was anderes geredet. Über das Radio, über die Zukunft, weil er wieder Radio macht. Bei Bayern 1 oder bei Bayern 1?
Wahrscheinlich. Könnte auch Bayern 3 sein, hört sich inzwischen an wie Bayern 1.
Genau, ich höre gern Bayern 1. Ich bin ein alter Mensch. Aber das sind Dinge, die mich noch interessieren. Wir hatten einmal Harald Schmidt bei uns ganz zu Beginn. Da hat Oliver Fassner ein tolles Interview gemacht. Das kannte Oliver auch fantastisch. Das interessiert mich auch ein kleines bisschen. Bei Fußball bin ich leider nicht gut genug drin.
Ja, aber das muss ja auch nicht schlimm sein. Ehrlich gesagt, das hört sich jetzt komisch an, weil ich hier gerade der Fußballtyp bin und ich jetzt gerade all meine Zeit und mein Geld darauf setze, mit Fußball gucken, irgendwie mein Geld zu verdienen. Aber ich finde, das eigentlich bessere ist, es sich nicht im Fußball auszukennen, weil das machen ja schon alle. Es hat ja niemand darauf gewartet, dass jetzt hier noch ein Typ aus Giesingen ums Eck kommt mit einem Fußballpodcast. Das muss man sagen. Nein, das ist so eine Filterblasenwahrnehmung. Also ja, klar, es läuft nicht schlecht und ich will mich nicht beschweren. Aber das, was wir zwei machen, das ist schon... Du sagst immer, das ärgert mich übrigens, wenn du immer von deinen 12 Hörern sprichst. Zum einen sind es auch Hörerinnen, hoffe ich zumindest.
Mindestens eine, ja. Da war Markus Gaub ein bisschen enttäuscht, dass unsere eine Hörerin, die wir namentlich kennen, nicht vergangenen Mittwoch im Stadion an der Schleißseimer Straße war. Entschuldige, ich habe dich unterbrochen.
Nee, alles gut. Aber da ärgere ich mich immer, wenn du dann die 12 Hörer zitierst, weil ich mir denke, jetzt stell doch nicht mehr dein Licht so unter den Scheffel.
Ich versuche mir einfach, nicht so wichtig zu nehmen. Weil genau das, was du sagst, ich kann nichts erzählen, was nicht Lothar Matthäus oder Matthias Sammer, der bei dir war, Sammer finde ich großartig. Ich habe es gestern wieder in der Halbzeitanalyse angeschaut. Das ist einfach fantastisch. Er animiert, er macht natürlich eine Show, er weiß, dass er eine Show macht. Aber wie er sie macht, ist grandios. Das ist einfach fantastisch. Es ist no-nonsense. Ich erinnere mich noch 2013. Wann haben die Bayern verloren gegen Inter Mailand in Madrid 2012? Ich glaube 2011.
10.
Oder 10. Gut, wo Sammer und Effenberg mit Sebastian Hellmann dort sitzen in Madrid. Und Hellmann hat gesagt, naja, Finale ist ja auch gut. Und Effenberg und Sammer sagen sich, scheiße, wenn du ein Finale verlierst. Dann haben sie das Spiel dann so großartig auseinandergenommen. Und ich will nur sagen, das kann ich nicht. Und deswegen nehme ich mich als selbst oder versuche mich selbst nicht zu ernst zu nehmen. Weil die einzige Sportart, wo ich mich ein bisschen auskenne, ist Tennis. Also wo ich in der Materie drinnen bin und wo mir jetzt nicht jemand sofort einen Geschichtl erzählen kann. Und vielleicht beim Skifahren. Nur beim Skifahren gibt es nicht so viele Geheimnisse, aber beim Tennis gibt es. Das ist das Schöne am Fußball, Max.
Und beim Nesca arbeitest du dich schon ganz schön hörbar rein. Also ich würde sagen, innerhalb des letzten Jahres.
Ich finde manchmal Nesca nicht. Ich verspreche immer, dass ich Nesca schauen werde. Und dann finde ich es aber manchmal nicht. Es war mal auf Kanal 430, Motorvision TV. Irgendwie finde ich es jetzt nicht mehr so richtig. Und das mache ich wirklich nur Pete Fink und Stefan Heinrich und Stefan Elen zuliebe, dass ich das mache. Weil Nesca bei aller Liebe. Aber mir erschließt sich die Faszination. Ich versuche mich da rein.
Ehrlich, ich bin nämlich jetzt inzwischen kurz davor, die ersten Rennen zu gucken. Also ich bin immer sehr vorsichtig beim Ausprobieren neuer Sportarten, weil bei Sport bin ich schon ein Suchtmensch. Und dann gucke ich zu viel davon. Und deswegen, da muss ich dann reduzieren, weil irgendwo hört es einfach auf. Aber bei Nesca bin ich so kurz davor, mit reinzuschauen.
Mach es bitte, mach es bitte. Ich möchte dich unbelastet in die Nesca reinschicken. Und du wirst dann mir vielleicht sagen können, ob es dir gefällt oder nicht. Ich habe meine Gründe, warum ich jetzt nicht 100% begeistert bin davon. Diese Gründe habe ich. Das sind in manchen Sportarten...
Ja, ich glaube sogar, so ein bisschen Gefühl dafür zu haben, in welche Richtung das geht. Aber gut, das ist ein anderes Thema. Aber wenn wir schon bei deinem Motorsport-Segment sind, muss ich eine Frage stellen, die... Wer hat mich das denn gefragt? Ich glaube, Sternburg war es, den du ja auch kennen dürftest. Er hat mich gefragt, warum eigentlich The Voice? Stefan The Voice Heinrich.
Hat nicht ich ihm gegeben den Spitznamen, sondern ich habe wie immer klein begonnen. Der erste Nesca-Mensch oder der erste Motorsport-Mensch, war Christian Nimmer von formel1.de. Und dann habe ich ihn mal gefragt, kennst du noch jemand? Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, Pete Fink kenne ich. Dann haben wir lange mit Pete Fink geredet. Und dann sagt er, Pete, ich habe da jemanden, den Stefan Heinrich, den ich nicht kannte, was ein großes Verschleunnis meinerseits ist.
Das macht dich nur menschlich, Jens.
Ja, aber ich kannte ihn wirklich nicht. Und dann sagt er aber, Pete Fink zu mir, das ist The Voice. Den kennt man als The Voice. Und dann sag ich Oliver Fassner, weißt du, wer jetzt zum Motorsport kommt? Und er sagt, ja. Und er sagt, weiß ich nicht. Sag ich Stefan. Was der Stefan Heinrich? Und da bin ich dann noch kleiner geworden, weil Stefan Heinrich eine Legende ist. Stefan Heinrich, jetzt am kommenden Wochenende wird er für die Formel E in Berlin wieder den Stadionsprecher geben. Ist bei der DTM in Hockenheim der Stadionsprecher. Das wusste ich alles nicht. Also Stefan Heinrich kennt jede Motorsportart, wirklich jeden Fahrer, jedes Modell, worauf es ankommt. Aber The Voice, diesen Spitznamen, den hat er mitgebracht, habe nicht ich ihm gegeben. Und er lebt gut damit. Hoffentlich. Aber er arbeitet wie ein Berserker. Er fliegt ungelungen für einen Rennen für zwei Tage. Fliegt er nach Australien um dort die australische V8 Serie auf Einladung, fliegt da rüber, schaut sich zwei Tage bei dem Rennen, fliegt wieder zurück und das ist Wahnsinn.
Das ist echt unglaublich. Aber man lernt so viel. Also gerade, dass es in Australien eine funktionierende Tourenwagenmeisterschaft gibt und nirgendwo sonst.
Als gutes Vorbild.
Die DTM sterben wird. Das weiß ich nur aus der Big Shot. Ich kann es echt nur empfehlen. Und das ist aber auch die Sache mit dem, ja klar, man soll sich selbst nicht zu wichtig nehmen, ist so ein schmaler Grat. Ein bisschen muss man nach außen auch, ein bisschen posen, sage ich jetzt fast schon, weil dadurch kriegst du neue Leute ran. Ich meine, ich bin ja hier auch auf so einem ständigen Grat beim Rasenfunk zwischen hier guckt die neue Folge, bitte, bitte unbedingt anhören. Aber eigentlich weiß ich schon auch, na ja, also frag mal. Du müsstest wahrscheinlich schon 100.000 Leute in Deutschland fragen, ob sie einen Rasenfunk kennen, damit einer sagt, ja. Also es reicht schon nicht mal, mit 1000 oder 10.000 zu befragen. Also das ist so ein komischer Mittelweg, den wir da gehen müssen. Aber das, was du da machst mit der Big Show, das gibt es halt nirgendwo sonst. Es gibt so ein paar ähnliche Ideen, die später dann aufkamen. Aber keiner macht das so in einem Format, das irgendwie zwischen drei Stunden roundabout dauert. Was viele Leute abschreckt. Aber hier im Rasenfunk kann man sowas sagen, ohne dass die Leute mit der Wimper zucken. Weil die wissen sofort, ja geil, das ist für mich, das ist ja für mich zweimal joggen oder irgendwie dreimal zur Arbeit.
Das ist das Feedback, das ich auch bekomme. Und Bushi sagt mir auch, du musst kürzer werden. Oder Markus Gaub sagt, die Big Show ist zu lang. Aber nee, ist sie nicht. Wer es nicht hören möchte, der soll es nicht hören. Man kann die Segmente einzeln anhören. Aber wenn man es durchhören möchte, also ich bin wirklich auch, wenn du den Motorsport-Teil ansprichst, ich bin schlauer geworden. Mich hat die DTM wirklich nie interessiert. Aber jetzt denke ich mir, warum geht Mercedes da raus? Warum kommt jetzt kein neuer? Warum ist das für die Japaner? Warum sagen die nicht sofort, da muss ich rein? Weil es ist eine Rennserie, ich präsentiere mich im deutschen Fernsehen. Und die haben ja die Kohle, warum machen die das nicht? Und das sind eben so viele Dinge. Oder Golf zum Beispiel, der Gregor Biernat. Golf habe ich davor schon angeschaut. Aber der Gregor, der erzählt natürlich auch ein bisschen hinter den Kulissen, was da los ist. Und gut, über Basketball müssen wir nicht reden, Andre Vogt. Und auch Septu Mitru, manchmal, wenn er am Start ist. Die sind natürlich total tief drin und Reys auch drüben. Und das ist eben, mein Anspruch ist einfach, ich möchte da vieles abdecken, was mich interessiert. Und wenn dann mal ein Marathon-Läufer dabei ist, von dem ich ungelogen davor noch nie was gehört habe, von dem mir aber Johannes Knut gesagt hat, ah, der ist gut, der hat was zu sagen. Und dann kommt der Johannes von der Süddeutschen Zeitung dazu und dann redet mehr er mit dem, als ich mit ihm rede. Aber das höre ich gerne. Oder wenn wir über Radsport sprechen. Jetzt haben wir über den Giro gesprochen. Und früher mal, ich weiß nicht, wie es dir gegangen ist, Max, aber du bist auch deutlich jünger als ich, aber 97, 800, dann die Lance Armstrong Jahre. Ich bin vorm Fernseher gesessen, auch im Büro, im Büro habe ich meinen Fernseher angehabt und habe sechs Stunden lang Tour de France geschaut, wie die Alpe d'Huez oder sonstigen dort aufgefahren sind. Und da bin ich geprägt davon. Also das Einzige, was ich mit Bushi gemein habe, und ich mag Frank Bushman wirklich sehr, also wirklich, aber Bushi ist auch jemand und Michael Körner auch und Marco Hagemann auch und du wahrscheinlich auch, der sich halt einfach jeden Scheiß anschaut. Also wirklich jeden Sport und im Zweifel sogar Bogenschießen, das macht Kai Pahle auch Bogenschießen bei den Olympischen Spielen.
Genau, und sowas wie Darsan war für Leute wie uns ganz, ganz schlecht. Weil auf einmal kommt jetzt immer was, was auch noch kommentiert wird. Das heißt, ich mache da wirklich zu großen Tageszeiten einen Bogen rum, weil ich weiß, naja, das läuft zwar nur auf dem Second-Screen, aber wenn das jetzt sportlich mitreißend ist, dann wird der Second sehr schnell zum First-Screen. Das ist... Aber das ist ja... Ist ja schön, dass es sowas gibt. Und ich habe auch bei der Big Show schon so viel gelernt. Und ich finde es auch einfach so großartig, immer zu hören, das war mein großer Aha-Moment, als ich von Elfreunde zu Spox gewechselt bin. Bei Elfreunde habe ich ganz viel übers Schreiben gelernt. Und, also damals, als ich den... Da habe ich ja auch den Elfreunde-Live-Ticker häufig geschrieben. Hättest du mir damals gesagt, schreibe einen Text, 5.000 Zeichen, hätte ich den eine halbe Stunde gehabt. Und der war fünfmal besser gewesen, als jetzt, wo ich es mir echt aus den Rippen schneiden musste, mit allem, was ich hatte. Und du bist auch einfach sehr höflich und ein sehr guter Gast. Aber das, was mir wirklich die Augen geöffnet hat, war, ich bin dann von Freunden weggekommen und mit denen, da kannst du ja sagen, Eintracht Braunschweig, Saison 66, 67, wissen wir natürlich die große Saison für Eintracht Braunschweig. Wer war denn da nochmal in der Innenverteidigung? Und dann kommen die ums Eck und erzählen dann auch gleich die drei lustigsten Anekdoten dazu. Wenn du sie aber fragst, wie hat denn am letzten Bundesliga-Spiel der HHSV gespielt, dann kommen sie so ins Stocken. Ja, weiß nicht, ich hab sie nur im Videotext angeguckt. So, jetzt überschwitzt gesprochen. Und dann komme ich zu Spocks und nicht nur, dass die dann alle logischerweise im aktuellen Fußballgeschäft drinhängen, sondern da läuft dann zum Beispiel ein Flo Regelmann rum, der aktuelle Sportschef, und der weiß halt alles, aber nur in Sportarten, die eigentlich sonst niemand interessiert. Also der kann dir zu Leichtathletik alles erzählen, du weißt zum US-Sport alles, der ist ein Riesengolf-Fan.
Und ist ein absoluter Tennis-Experte?
Ist ein Tennis-Experte, man kann wunderbar mit ihm, aber das fand ich so faszinierend. Und die Leute hast du ja in deiner Big Show, diese Leute, die, ich hätte jetzt fast Inselbegabung gesagt, aber das führt in eine falsche Richtung, aber die sich für etwas anderes als Fußball mit der gleichen Leidenschaft interessieren, für die ich mich für Fußball interessiere. Und das finde ich total faszinierend. Und ich finde es schade, dass diejenigen so selten Platz bekommen in der Aufmerksamkeitsspanne, die man so hat in der Medienwelt. Weil es gibt dann halt einen Zyklus zu olympischen Spielen, ist es auf einmal auch wieder interessant, Leichtathletik zu hören. Aber ansonsten interessiert es keinen, überhaupt nicht.
Wie viele Leute wissen, dass in diesem Jahr die Leichtathletik, ich glaube es ist die Europameisterschaft, ich bin mir nicht mal sicher, ob es nicht vielleicht die Weltmeisterschaft ist, aber ich glaube es ist die Europameisterschaft in Berlin, aber wie viele Leute wissen das denn tatsächlich? Und wie viele Leute können da zwei Athleten nennen, wenn Harting nicht mehr dabei ist, auf wie viele Leichtathleten kommen wir denn in Deutschland?
Das geht mir aber auch so, und ich würde mich als sportinteressierten Menschen bezeichnen.
Mit Buschi haben wir vor den Olympischen Spielen gesprochen, und ich habe gesagt, Frank, ich stelle bei mir selbst fest, ich bin bei den deutschen Langläufern, bei Tobias Angerer hängengeblieben, ich könnte jetzt nicht sagen, wer ist eigentlich ein aktueller deutscher Langläufer? Und der Busch hat mich dann getröstet, nicht so schlimm, Buschi hat natürlich den ganzen Kader runter raten können. Und Thomas Wagner, um vielleicht noch einen Namen zu bringen, der Thomas ist halt jemand, der das erste Mal dabei war, und man hat gedacht, was ist denn das für ein Typ? Der sagt, gestern war ich mit meiner Tochter beim Wasserball in Niederlande gegen Deutschland, das war so geil, und meine Tochter ist zum Wasserball-Fan geworden. So etwas ist großartig, weil ich finde schon, dass der Fußball so viel Aufmerksamkeit hat, und jetzt bei der Fußballin bin ich ja der Gleiche. Der sagt, mir ist es völlig wurscht, was die FIFA macht, ich möchte diese Spiele jetzt sehen, und mir ist es auch fast egal, wo es stattfindet. Ich bin sogar der Meinung, dass ganz grundsätzlich ein Land wie Russland irgendwann mal eine WM verdient hätte. Das mag jetzt blöd klingen, und im Moment politisch ist es überhaupt nicht opportun, und ich finde es auch grauslich, was da politisch stattfindet, auch mit dieser HJ. Seppelt-Geschichte, der jetzt gnadenhalber einreisen darf, weil, wie auch immer, vielleicht warst du der deutsche Außenminister. Nur grundsätzlich, ein Land wie Russland, das eine große Tradition hat, das riesengroß ist, warum nicht dort eine Fußballwettmeisterschaft, aber die Schweinereien, die in der FIFA losgehen, du hast hier bei dir die Football-Leaks liegen. Ich bin auch natürlich ein sklavischer Leser von allem, was Thomas Kisten in der Süddeutschen schreibt, und auch dieses, wie heißt es, Mafia-FIFA oder FIFA-Mafia, dieses Buch natürlich auch gelesen. Da darf man ja nirgendwo meine Fußball-WM veranstalten. Aber das verzeihe ich dem Fußball dann. Und Thomas Hahn hat auch geschrieben, meine Frage ist, warum verzeihe ich es dem IOC nicht mehr? Warum regt mich das beim IOC auf, dass die Olympischen Winterspiele in Peking stattfinden, die überhaupt keinen Winter haben dort? Und beim Fußball, da muss ich mich selbst auch manchmal, ärgere ich mich über mich, der zieht mich dann halt manchmal noch rein. Aber ich finde es halt schade, dass ich dann auch teilweise unkritisch bin, wenn das WM-Stadion St. Petersburg dort ist. Und für uns macht es als TV-Zuschauer letztlich keinen Unterschied zu 2006, wo dann WM-Stadion Gelsenkirchen da gestanden ist. Und jetzt haben wir halt Moskau und die Banden schauen eh gleich aus. Und das ist halt sehr gleichförmig. Wenn wir jetzt alte Bilder anschauen aus Argentinien oder damals aus München 1974, ist es natürlich Wahnsinn.
Ja, das sieht so fast aus wie eine Kirmesveranstaltung im Nachhinein. Aber das ist ja genau das Dilemma, in dem sich eigentlich jeder Sportfan, der ein bisschen über nur das rein Sportliche hinwegguckt, befindet. Dass vor allem im Fußball es so viele Dinge gibt, die schieflaufen, die man nicht gut heißen kann, dass man sich die Frage stellt, okay, kann das das Spiel noch rausreißen? Und wir sind halt dann noch gerade in der Situation, wo uns das Spiel immer noch so fesselt. Es ist halt einfach ein tolles Spiel, muss man einfach sagen. Trotz aller anderen Sportarten, es gibt einen Grund, warum der Fußball sich so durchgesetzt hat. Aber man hat schon große Bauchschmerzen. Und so Leute wie wir, die drüber berichten, können dann eigentlich nur den Mittelweg gehen, dass man bei den Dingen, die schieflaufen im Fußball, auch drauf zeigt und darüber berichtet und das nicht ausblendet. Man muss es nicht bei jedem Satz abwägend mit sagen. Aber es gehört dazu.
Das ist schon der Anspruch. Und auf der anderen Seite, aber du weißt ja, oder du weißt es vielleicht nicht, aber ich weiß nicht, wie du dich weiterbildest, aber ich versuche mir ja schon Inspiration aus den USA zu holen. Und die Show, wo ich mich am meisten wiederfinden würde gerne, ist eben die Dan Lebertard Show with Stu Guts. Kennst du sie ein bisschen?
Noch nicht reingehört, nur vom Namen her. Ich höre wenn dann Bill Simmons.
Bill Simmons, der damit wirklich reich geworden ist. Da musst du noch ein bisschen arbeiten, muss man sagen.
Da müsste ich aber auch zum Beispiel Sportwettenfolgen machen.
Da habe ich keine Lust drauf. Also das mit Cousins Cell, das macht er manchmal. Aber gut, da hat ESPN natürlich früh erkannt. Der bringt uns so viele Leser, den holen wir ein. Aber dieser Dan Lebertard und Stu Guts, das ist ein brillanter Journalist, Dan Lebertard, der wirklich gut ist in dem, was er macht, wenn man dem zuhört. Da kommen nur schlaue Sätze raus. Er hat einen kubanischen Vater und wohnt in Miami. Das ist in Amerika einfach auch einfach. Du hast vier Sportarten, wo fast immer was los ist. Und er, mit seiner ganzen Herkunft, kann auch immer über Rasse sprechen. Das ist natürlich ein großes Problem, das wir dort haben. Aber für die Sportpodcaster, finde ich, oder für die Sportradio ist es in gewisser Weise auch ein kleiner Segen, weil du halt diese Kontroverse immer hast. Wo du weißt, die Leute, das bewegt sie richtig. Und was da teilweise kommt an Kommentaren auf Twitter, das ist grauslich. Das ist wirklich grauslich. Aber dein Leopard hat es so gut, dass er das Ganze auffängt. Ich habe ein Beispiel gelesen. Mittlerweile ist er, wenn es denn stimmt, der Podcast, der am meisten gehört wird in den USA. Aber als Beispiel, wenn er hören würde, dass Sir Alex Ferguson nach einer Niederlage irgendeinen Spieler, da gab es noch mal diesen Fall, wo er, da war es Arsene Wenger, durch die Kabine mit einem Schuh beworfen hat.
Der wird Beckham angeblich.
Ja, dann würde aber der Leopard interessieren, welcher Schuh war es, wie dreckig war der, welche Marke würde sich am besten eignen, dass man einen Schuh wirft. Und dann würde er bei Nike, Adidas und sonst wo anrufen und fragen, welchen Schuh würden sie denn empfehlen. Natürlich redet er auch darüber, wen die Miami Dolphins draften sollten. Er gehört halt auch dazu. Aber er schafft es, diese Balance und dieser Stugatz.
Das ist die Antwort ja auch einfach so ziemlich jedem. Also die Dolphins können gegenbrauchen.
Ja, die können jeden nehmen. Der hat halt seinen Punching-Bag. Dieser Stugatz nimmt diese Rolle an und sagt, ich bin halt der gemeine Fan. Der brabelt vor sich hin und der ist aber auch sehr, sehr gut in dem, was er tut. Und diese Balance zwischen, und ich habe deinen Vortrag auf Republika immer das angeschaut, das war sehr, sehr gut. Und du sagst ja auch, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, dieses Abdriften ins Boulevard Desque, das findet halt einfach mal statt. Und du hast da, glaube ich, Mario Basso als Video gebracht.
Das war fast schon zu einfach.
Aber meine Frage, die ich mir halt jeden Tag stelle, ist, nehmen wir den Fußball zu wichtig? Wo sind denn die guten Geschichten? Ist nicht Sandro Wagner jemand, für den wir ein Kerzchen anzünden sollten eigentlich, weil es endlich mal eine gute Geschichte ist? Und weil der ja wirklich, also manchmal sagt er Sachen, wo ich mir denke, Bezug zur Realität komplett verloren. Und manchmal denke ich mir, eigentlich hat er recht. Und da gibt es eben...
Ja, vor allem sagt er auch einfach Dinge. Nee, ich glaube, ich weiß schon, was du meinst. Es ist letztlich die Frage, wie du den Sport verstehst, als Unterhaltungsindustrie oder erst mal als Sport. Und es ist völlig legitim, eigentlich das Drumherum zu machen. Also ich glaube auch, dass so ein Format, wie du es jetzt gerade beschrieben hast, das müsste eigentlich auch in Deutschland funktionieren können. Weil Deutschland ist ein sportbegeistertes Land, nur leider hat Deutschland da sehr viele blinde Flecken, nämlich alle Sportarten außer Fußball. Aber dafür sind sie so sportbegeistert, dass du tatsächlich über viele Dinge reden kannst. Und man kann hier auch über diese Nebenthemen angenehm reden. Also so, wie du es gerade beschrieben hast, das ist ja ein netter und lustiger Ansatz. Und auch mit diesem Spiegeln, dass du auch mal die einfache Wahrheit dann hinterfragst. Und es muss nicht immer so akademisch sein, wie es im Rasenfunk ist. Ich finde es nur erstaunlich, dass sogar, das hört sich jetzt sehr polemisch an, aber ich finde sogar der Populismus ist im Sport-Jewelismus plump. Also nicht mal da geben sie sich Mühe. Es ist so lieblos einfach in vielen Dingen.
Die Lieblosigkeit, vielleicht ist es auch dadurch bedingt, dass alles schnell gehen muss und dass man sich nicht mehr genug Gedanken macht. Aber ein bisschen Nuancen, ein bisschen Reizen. Und Reizen meine ich jetzt nicht, dass man, wie du sagst, plump jetzt, als Schalke-Fan sagt, ich finde den BVB doof. Da muss mehr kommen. Und es gibt ja viele Blogger, bei denen kommt ja auch mehr. Bei denen es wirklich witzig ist. Und wenn du sagst akademisch, wenn Alex Feuerherd über die Schiedsrichter spricht, dann brauche ich es akademisch. Wirklich, dann muss ich, dann sage ich, und ich weiß, in 13 Minuten ist er bei dir zu Gast. Und das ist großartig, weil du sagst ja, wie der Alex spricht, das ist wie gedruckt und das brauche ich. Und dann vielleicht ist das Schiedsrichter-Thema auch eines, das sich nicht eignet, um wirklich ein bisschen flapsig drüber zu sprechen. Ja, ich weiß nicht, wo der Platz ist.
Das Schöne ist aber, ich finde, Alex Feuerherd und ja auch Klaas Reese, sein Kompagnon, sind das perfekte Beispiel dafür, was Podcasts leisten können. Die haben nämlich, die haben sich da selbst eine Plattform gesucht und sind jetzt dieser Plattform eigentlich entwachsen. Und Alex ist bei NTV und bei N24. Und ich sage dir, wir werden ihn zur WM häufiger in vielen Medien lesen, bin ich mir ziemlich sicher. Klaas Reese ist jetzt beim Deutschlandfunk. Das heißt, allein deswegen sind Podcasts großartig, weil sie einem die Möglichkeit geben können, weiterzukommen. Ja, genau. Und die Türen im Sportjournalismus sind auch schneller zu, als man so denkt, wenn man sich nicht an gewisse Regeln hält. Als Praktikant bist du halt der, da kann es dann auch mal sein, dass dein Redaktionsleiter sagt, du stellst dich jetzt bitte hier vor die Praxis von Dr. Müller-Wohlfahrt und rufst uns an, wer da aus der Tür rauskommt. Und wenn du dann jemand bist, also ist jetzt natürlich nicht stellvertretend für alle Stellen im Sportjournalismus, aber das kann passieren. Und wenn du dann jemand bist, der sagt, ja Moment mal, was soll denn das eigentlich bringen? Dann ist diese Tür bei diesem Medium für dich zu und dann musst du schon zum nächsten Medium. Und Podcasts sind halt unser eigenes. Das wird gerade der längste Kurzpass, den ich hier hatte.
Es tut mir sehr leid.
Na, aber es ist ja irgendwie passend, wenn ich die Macher der Big Show hier habe. Aber jetzt sag uns doch noch zum Abschluss, was können wir denn von dir zur WM hören? Wird es wieder Dailies geben?
Ja, es wird ein WM-Daily geben. Das sind dann wir gewissermaßen, vielleicht kompensieren wir uns.
Ich glaube, dass sich das sehr gut ergänzen wird, glaube ich wirklich.
Ja, also ich habe ja wieder meine Kollegen am Start mit eben, ja, das Potpourri der gesammelten Erfolge mit dem Alexi, der sicherlich zu den Frankreichspielen was sagen wird. Also in Grunde genommen sind alle dabei. Die interessante Komponente wird sein beim Daily, dass der Anchorman sich am Dienstag aufmacht nach Schottland. Ich wusste auch nicht, dass er nach Schottland fährt. Ja, wie du weißt das nicht. Anchorman hat noch den letzten freien Parkplatz bekommen bei der Mountainbike WM in St. Schlagmichtoth. Er hat es mir gestern zweimal gesagt. Hab ich schon vergessen. Aber irgendwann in Schottland. Und den Anchorman werden wir natürlich immer reinholen und die Stimmung einfangen, wie gerade Schottler und ihr nicht dabei sind, die WM miterlebt. Also wir werden versuchen, wir werden nicht versuchen, wir werden täglich was machen. Das wird sich jetzt thematisch nicht so wahnsinnig von dir unterscheiden, glaube ich. Mit dem bewährten Personal. Also ich gehe davon aus, dass Marco ab und zu dabei ist, Andreas Renner, Oli Seidler, halt große Teile des Sky Teams und werden auch versuchen, so wie wir es bei Olympia gehabt haben, dass ich zumindest ein paar Leute von der Süddeutschen Zeitung anzapfen kann. Also Johannes Aumüller und Claudio Cartugno. Das hat ja auch in Rio gut funktioniert. Also ich weiß noch, Claudio hatten wir sogar über Skype am Start, als die chilenischen Fans das Pressezentrum im Maracana gestürmt haben.
Stimmt, das habe ich gehört.
Also da war Claudio, was ist jetzt los? Okay, kenne ich mir nicht aus. Also das wird es zur WM geben. Und man kann übrigens dieses WM-Heft, wenn ich nochmal so schamlos Werbung betreiben darf, es ist zeitlos. Man kann dieses WM-Heft auch nach Beginn der WM noch bestellen, weil die Informationen, die da drin sind, sind so gut wie zuvor.
Das stimmt, wobei ich es anders formulieren würde. Bestellen, definitiv jetzt, sonst sind sie nämlich auf jeden Fall vergriffen. Denn das ist ein Sammlerobjekt, liebe Leute. Aber ihr könnt es ja erst nach der WM konsumieren, so hat es der liebe Jens natürlich gesagt.
Großartig, steilpassedspotradio360.de Genau, lasst euch das nicht entgehen. Ah, bitte die Adresse angeben.
Adresse mit angeben und dann holt euch zwölf Titelverteidiger. Es lohnt sich auf jeden Fall sehr. Hört auch die Dailies, ich glaube, wirst du wieder nachts veröffentlichen. Das war doch, genau, deswegen ergänzen wir uns nämlich schon gut. Bei mir ist immer die Aufnahme um zehn, dann kommt es so zwischen elf und halb zwölf online. Das heißt, man hat erst deinen schon locker weggehört und dann kommt noch mal ein Kurzpass. Und dann kann man realitätsabgleichen. Und dann wäre ich aber auch gar nicht sicher, wie gut ich dann da stehe. Da muss ich mich schon strecken. Ich habe jedes Daily gehört zur Europameisterschaft. Und zwar sehr gerne. Vor allem wegen der Gäste. Das war... Das hat sich jetzt unhöflich angehört, so war es nicht gemeint.
Es war insofern ein Spagat, weil das war gerade die Zeit von Wimbledon. Ich war in London und habe bei meiner... Ich war dort zur Miete, die hat gelesen, Jens hat gedacht, eine Frau kommt, und ich stehe bei der vor der Tür und sage, Who are you? Und ich sage, na, ich bin Jens. Und die hat mich dann aber alle eingelassen für drei Tage, weil sie irgendwo hingefahren ist, und dann bin ich bei der im Wohnzimmer gesessen und habe meine EM-Dalys aufgenommen.
Stark.
Dieses Internet ist crazy.
Ja, total. Ich kann dir jetzt schon sagen, Skype nach Russland raschelt manchmal ein bisschen. Ich habe ja schon ein paar Schalten gemacht, da muss man noch gucken, aber vielleicht schafft man es ja anders. Jens, vielen herzlichen Dank, dass du da warst. Das hat großen Spaß gemacht.
Ich habe zu danken.
Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, holt euch auf jeden Fall das Magazin 12 Titelverteidiger Steilpass at sportradio360.de da bitte die Adresse reinschreiben. Ihr werdet es nicht bereuen. Und wenn ihr bei Sportradio 360 noch nicht reingehört habe, dann möchte ich euch zwei Fragen stellen. Zum ersten, warum? Und zum zweiten, was seid ihr für Menschen? Tut es bitte. Wenn ihr euch für Sport interessiert, dann müsst ihr die Big Show des Sportradios 360 hören. Minimum. Und ansonsten hören wir uns bald wieder. Bis dahin eine gute Zeit.